[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment
of harry potter theory in today's video
we're going to be discussing dementors i
love dementors
they're some of the coolest creatures in
the harry potter universe
and it occurred to me today that i
hadn't made a dementor video
in a while which made me sad so i had
some chocolate
i hope you get the reference anyway i
thought a ten dementor facts video
would provide some nice contrast to the
sunny beautiful weather outside the
moment
for those unaware dementors are cloaked
creatures that are three meters tall
with dark grey scabby skin dementors are
foul creatures
that represent unhappiness and despair
they were created by rowling
as a way of personifying all of the
negative aspects of depression
with that charming introduction out of
the way let's get into
10 facts about the horrifying creatures
known as dementors
number one they were extra drawn to
harry
this relates to voldemort's relationship
to harry
on wednesday october 31st voldemort
traveled to the town of godric's hollow
where the potter family lived voldemort
had plans to murder harry
however the loving sacrifice that lily
had put in place
ensured that harry was protected which
meant that voldemort's killing curse
came firing right back at him and what
voldemort essentially
unwittingly did on this day was turn
harry into a horcrux
you see when voldemort tried to kill
harry the curse rebounded which split
voldemort's soul
but because voldemort's body was gone
the victim of his own curse
he could no longer encase the soul
fragment to complete the horcrux
formation
because voldemort's soul was left
without any attachment
it latched itself to harry for this
reason harry contained voldemort's soul
fragment
but was never possessed by it so why
were dementors
extra drawn to harry well the dementors
were attracted to the extra soul that
harry carried with him
unwillingly harry went about his life
with an extra soul
strapped to him and i think that this
made him a target to dementors
a sort of two for the price of one to a
dementor
harry was the ultimate treat number two
they were created by a dark wizard named
acrysdis
probably a christus isn't particularly
well known but he certainly marked his
place in wizarding history
as he was a practitioner of the worst
kinds of dark arts imaginable
very little is known about acrystus
other than the fact that he was alive
during the 15th century and that he was
evil pure evil
no one knows his nationality and even if
it was known
i'm sure no one would want to claim
ownership of him he was that bad
a christus was the original inhabitant
of the island fortress of azkaban
what we now know as the prison that
holds some of the darkest witches and
wizards
within its walls while traveling in the
15th century
acrysdis stumbled upon the island which
at the time had no infrastructure to
speak of
when he first arrived it was just a
regular island but he soon turned it
into his own little dark arts experiment
echristis began his dark arts
experiments by luring
muggle sailors to the island then
torturing and eventually murdering them
he became so wrapped up and enthralled
in his experimentation with dark magic
that he had lost his mind and the poor
sailors that he lured to the island
witnessed it firsthand in his madness it
has been speculated that accidents
either unwittingly or perhaps
intentionally created
what we now know to be dementors number
three
underneath the cloak now when we think
of a dementor we often just think of
floating
ominous looking black cloaks soaring
through the air
we might even think of that old decrepit
looking hand
that sometimes jets out of the sleeve
however what many don't think about
is just how horrifying dementors look
underneath that cloak
the physical form of a dementor is
essentially akin to a rotting corpse
they're grey full of moisture and
decomposing from the top
down not only that but they're over
three meters tall
with massive cavities where their eyes
are supposed to be as well as a demonic
looking hole
that's meant to be their mouth they are
some of the creepiest looking creatures
with a cloacon but let's just be
thankful that they were a cloak
at all number four dementors and animeji
i bet a lot of you didn't know this one
that's right and the magi
are a little bit safer from dementors
than your run-of-the-mill witch or
wizard
for those unaware an animagus simply put
is a witch or wizard that is able to
transform themselves into an animal
and back again as sirius explained he
would utilize his animagus form
while imprisoned in azkaban in order to
protect some of his memories from mental
rot
the dementors inside of the prison were
not fully able to distinguish sirius
from his animal form
which explains why he was able to endure
his time in the prison
so well furthermore transforming helped
in allowing him to escape
from the prison number five the
dementors kiss
so we know that dementors attack people
and we know that we should be scared of
them
but how do they actually hurt us well as
it turns out
dementors pose a significant threat to
witches and wizards alike
because of their kiss now there's no hug
involved in this case
and this kiss probably isn't the kind
that you're accustomed to
when a dementor kisses someone they
immobilize their body
grab onto their face and proceed to
begin sucking out their soul
the soul of a dementor's victim can
literally be sucked out of them
leaving them alive but empty number six
dudley dursley and dementors in august
of 1995
we see harry and dudley dursley chased
by dementors
unable to escape dudley is attacked but
after his escape
we're never told what it is that harry's
childhood bully
saw dudley seemed incapable of saying
he shuddered again and shook his large
blonde head and
despite the sense of numb dread that had
settled on harry since the arrival of
the first
owl he felt a certain curiosity
dementors caused a person to relive
the worst moments of their life what
would spoiled
pampered bullying dudley have been
forced to hear as it turns out
jk rowling actually answered this in an
interview
people usually ask me what is it that
dudley saw during the dementor attack
rolling said my feeling is that he saw
himself
exactly for what he was and for a boy
that spoiled
it would be terrifying so he was jolted
out of it
dementor attacks aren't usually good for
people but this one was
number seven the ministry of magic and
dark wizards like voldemort
hire them the ministry of magic
certainly have a knack of making some
questionable decisions
however one of their most questionable
decisions dates back to the 1700s
when they first hired dementors to work
for them
as it turns out dementors have served
for a long time
the ministry of magic first hired
dementors back in 1718
when new minister for magic damocles
raoul was elected
raul saw the dementors as a potential
asset and
rather than trying to get rid of them
felt that he could utilize their
abilities at azkaban helping to keep
dark prisoners in check
knowing that the prison needed guards
ralph felt by using extant
non-beings like dementors he would be
able to prevent
endangering the lives of witch or wizard
guards
but why you might ask now would
dementors serve the ministry of magic
the main reason was that the ministry
allowed the dementors to
feed on the emotions of the prisoners
within its walls
on that note it should also be mentioned
that the dementors will basically serve
whoever
is in power under the ministry they're
allowed to feed on prisoners
and under voldemort they're allowed to
feed on many others
number eight intelligence and sentience
just because we don't hear dementors
speak because we don't see dementors
particularly interact with anything or
anyone outside of kissing them it
doesn't mean that they aren't
intelligent
in fact they are extremely smart
creatures that show all kinds of signs
of sentience
interestingly enough the ministry of
magic actually classifies them
as non-beings which by definition
means a type of magical spirit created
out of human emotions
a classification which they share with
poltergeists like peeves
their ability to coordinate attacks and
switch sides as need be
are other clear indicators of their
unassuming intelligence
number nine they have their own language
that's right
dementors speak well at least with each
other
however with that said we have
absolutely no idea what their language
is
what it sounds like or if anyone can
understand it
what we do know however is that the
dementors relayed
certain information about sirius's
behavior in jail to ministry officials
so either they can speak a wisdom
language in common with someone at the
ministry
or someone at the ministry can speak the
language of the dementors
either one sounds terrifying number 10
how to stop them
there are two known ways to stop
dementors the first is the patronus
charm
a patronus charm is produced when a
witch or wizard cast the spell
expecto patronum there are two types of
patronus charms
corporeal and incorporeal and the type
that the witch or wizard casts
will depend on their experience
preference
the second way to stop a dementor is a
lot less technical
chocolate however chocolate only helps
victims of dementors
it doesn't actually scare them away per
pottermore
the mood enhancing properties of
chocolate are well known in both the
muggle
and wizard worlds chocolate is the
perfect antidote
for anyone who's been overcome in the
presence of dementors
which sucks hope and happiness out of
their surroundings
and that's it for this terrifying list
of dementor facts
if you enjoyed the video please leave a
like a comment
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
remember happiness can be found even in
the darkest of times
if one only remembers to turn on the
[Music]
light
you